las calles de parís amanecieron vacías
este domingo las tiendas bajo llave y
algunos que pueden abrir sus
restaurantes esperan a que alguien
llegue horas antes del inicio del tercer
confinamiento las calles se veían así en
francia en medio de un aumento
vertiginoso del número de contagios
porque hoy 19 esta vez los comercios no
esenciales han cerrado en todo el país
aunque ya lo estaban en 19 departamentos
administrativos en el último día abierto
al público
la gente se apresuró a ir a las tiendas
para comprar todo lo que necesitara en
el próximo mes
julián convence que era positivo para
los dueños de las tiendas y venía hoy
antes de que cierren para no tener que
comprar en internet
en este tercer encierro las escuelas
permanecerán cerradas durante tres a
cuatro semanas la gente tendrá que
trabajar desde casa a menos que sea
imposible viajar de una región a otra
está prohibido a menos que haya una
razón de peso para hacerlo se espera que
el estado gaste por lo menos 11 mil
millones de euros en ayuda financiera
para cubrir las pérdidas de las empresas
los economistas dicen que los subsidios
pueden suavizar el golpe pero no
salvarán a todos los negocios
del 10 al 15 por ciento de las empresas
francesas podrían cerrar del todo debido
a esta crisis
muchas empresas ya no tendrán
suficientes fondos propios y eso es un
problema incluso con los subsidios no
podrán pagar todos los impuestos
comerciales algunos tendrán que cerrar y
el desempleo aumentará por su básica
a raíz del tercer confinamiento en las
autoridades han bajado sus expectativas
de crecimiento después de tener una
economía sorprendentemente lenta en 2020
el gobierno proyectó un crecimiento del
5 por ciento para 2021